[Music]
hey guys in this video I'm going to talk
about big spoilers that are coming from
the night king actor who spilled some
major spoilers about the third episode
of the final season if you've been
following a material on season 8 news
and leaked photos you know that there's
a big battle set to take place in season
8 although it's never been confirmed in
which episode will take place or even at
King is the one attacking until now now
thanks to the actor who plays the night
king vitamin Ferda Queen oh when will
this battle take place as well as how
will it look like a sea confirmed in
himself verdict letting you sleep during
a fan convention in Hungary he says and
spoils in the third episode of the last
season there's a battle that the
creator's intended to be a historic
moment in the television almost the full
episode will be about a battle it will
take about one hour verdict states that
they filmed this battle for three months
in the wind and the rain outdoors and
then for another month in a huge stereo
which makes this easily the longest
battle shoot in the show's history I can
tell you that there will be no shortage
of surprises in season eight Ferdie
continues there will be a lot of dragons
the night king will return and in season
the biggest battle for the throne will
be completed so basically for dick is
confirming that the big battle between
the living and dead will go down in
episode 3 at the end of season 7 the
army of the Dead now numbering over
100,000 White's as well as the White
Walkers is heading straight towards the
north bringing a Minter that will become
another long night the one which may
last forever
while most of the living on the other
hand is also heading north it's been
confirmed that the season 8 will open at
Winterfell with an episode that contains
plenty of callbacks to the show's pilot
instead of King Robert's procession
arriving it's Danny and her army what
follows is a thrilling and tense
intermingling of characters some of whom
have never previously met many who have
messy histories as they all prepare to
face the inevitable invasion of the army
of the dead so most of the main
characters will be at Winterfell at the
beginning of season 8 with Jaime and a
few more yet to arrive however it won't
be until two episodes later that the
living will face the night king and his
huge army white that long because the
night king will not start his conquest
at Winterfell the night king will hit
last heart and karhold first just as Jon
Snow predicted if they breach the wall
the first two castles in that path a
last hath and car whole this is what
John said in season 7 premiere and it
will likely come true in the season 8
premiere the rulers of those castles of
how sombre and how scarce art Ned amber
and Ellis car
serve will probably fall along after the
night king is done with them he will
proceed south arriving in Winterfell in
Episode three the living with Jon Snow
and Daenerys other champions will be
ready John man to Dragonstone not only
to meet the dragon queen but mainly to
mind dragon glass without which they
would not even stand a chance with John
and Dana's arrival at Winterfell of
course that they brought dragon lists
from gemstone to use it in the war to
come their armies will have all sorts of
jealous weapons from how birds to
daggers the insulted will have a
journalist tip Spears and archers will
have dragon glass arrowheads most of the
living will take a defensive position
behind line so she will de freeze the
dragon was sticking out of the spikes
some armies on the walls of Winterfell
some outside Winterfell
why outside not only with some of their
armies such as the trackie who are said
to be born fight and died in saddle be
useless if not fighting on an open field
but also because Winterfell is not big
enough to have all their armies inside
it
the unsullied will form a large unit
phalanx formation their famous battle
tactic large group of them fighting in
lockstep falen says using spear and
shield this formation they once defeated
an army that was approximately seven
times bigger in numbers true it's
different this time they're not facing
the living but the dead but it makes no
difference
the isalud will have dragonglass tipped
Spears Jon Brienne and Jaime will build
their Valyrian steel swords while it's
yet to be seen who milsim gave his own
Valyrian steel sword hearts bein such a
powerful weapon is not useful in the
hands of a maester san but it'd be
pretty useful in the hands of his friend
Jorah Mormont so yeah my guess is that
he will give it to Jorah but that just
me Arya will build her Valyrian steel
dagger and Barrett will have his flaming
sword ready
the battle for Winterfell begins this
battle is directed by me well supposing
the guy behind some of the biggest
episodes of Game of Thrones like
hardhome winds of winter and battled the
bastards Furtick said they filmed for
three months in the wind and rain
outdoors and then for another month in a
huge studio which has already said makes
this far invade the most labor-intensive
battle sequence in the show's history
and therefore in the history of TV for
reference the most elaborate battle
sequence the crew had filmed up to this
point was the battle the bastards in
season 6 for death the production was
parked at Saint field Ireland for over a
month the upcoming Winterfell battle
seen on the other hand requires shoots
of multiple occasions and lasted for
over twice that long and the end product
is all for a single episode
it's brutal said peter dinklage tyrion
lanister it makes the battle
look like a theme-park writing about
this historic sequence James Hebert
called it wall-to-wall action and
detailed heavy jumps between the stories
of several different characters the
showrunner David Benioff said that every
thread feels like its own genre having
the largest battle doesn't sound very
exciting it actually sounds pretty
boring a part of our challenge and
really mean Wells challenges how to keep
that compelling we have been building
toward this since the very beginning as
the living against the dead and you can
do that in a 12-minute sequence what
this means is basically while in the
battle from interval in season six we
followed only story so have very few
characters in this battle however almost
all the main characters are here and he
has to jump between the stories of all
these different characters we have John
snow made his direwolf fighting on the
ground and Dana met her dragons fighting
in the sky
we have Arya Stark the Hound Davos
barrack Jorah Thurman brilliant Podrick
reformed ginjury all the northern Lords
possibly theme Greyjoy bran and Jamie as
well fighting on the ground although the
story will probably full of Arya and
Jamie while all these other characters
are around them we also have brain sense
the same well same Gilly very strobe in
arena and tyrion all of whom might not
be the first line of defense but a story
will definitely fall of Tyrion in brain
Tyrion has shown himself to possess a
keen mind for strategy as evidenced in
his research into defending against
sieges and successfully conducting
defense of King's Landing during the
battle the Blackwater Tyrion will
definitely play an important role in
defending Winterfell from the night king
brain on the other hand is the key to
defeating the night king he is the only
one who can go back in past
learn how the first long night ended
learn how the night king was defeated
and share all game-changing information
with John and Danny I don't see brain
learning this until the very end since I
don't see the night king being defeated
until the very end of Game of Thrones if
at all so virile brains will be in the
battle for interval bran which at work
into the night Kings Dragon although
this attempt will fail because the deny
King's magic that is still way more
powerful than brains
frame will most probably manage to work
into the undead Giants and that may be
of a huge help for the living we have
never seen brain working into any one
from the knight king's army thus far but
he will likely be strong enough ready to
do so by the time winter arrives at
Winterfell
if brain manages to work into the end
enjoins denill it's a huge possibility a
brain will work into the night kings and
Dragoon as well at some point of the
season after all the tweet raven
detailed brain dead he will not walk
again
but he will fly the
we'll also full of the opposite side the
night king whose story beside clashing
with Dana's Val fighting her in the sky
might also clash with Jon Snow's as if
he's the land John would definitely rush
to fight the night king no matter how
many whites are between them sometime
during the battle for Winterfell ORS
dire wolf Cimmeria will probably join
the battle with her pack of wolves as
well made game appearance coming to its
end it only makes sense for die rolls to
finally reappear ghost was confirmed to
return and it was also confirmed that he
sees a lot of action in this episode and
I Miria will probably be here as well
during the battle for Winterfell some of
the best fighters around Jon Snow brie
Inari and protege me who might not be
great fighter anymore but his still a
brave warrior will pick a fight with the
White Walkers my letters are fighting
whites as seen in the previous season if
a vibe Walker dies divides the array as
the instantly collapses Val they know if
they're to kill a white Walker huge
amount of whites dies along that's their
only chance so Val winter fall at
Winterfell if you would like to know the
answer to this question it's time for
you to close this video and know that
you can expect the best battle in
history of television
ok if you could not tell by the official
teaser itself the winter will definitely
not fall at Winterfell this battle from
interval will be a huge defeat for the
living in this league photo of the
aftermath of the battle for Winterfell
we can see corpses of the brave soldiers
covering the fields of interval and
they're soon to be raised by the night
king to act as his minions whites the
mist Frost's the direwolf marker over as
well as the marker for day needs and
solid forces but unfortunately the
northern army and the unsullied are not
going to be the only casualties for the
living it's confirmed that most of the
track you will fall as well then shortly
after be brought back to life by the
White Walkers to basically act as their
minions here you can see the track you
is riding on horseback we have never
seen a white riding a horse but it will
change once to the track it becomes the
part of the knight king's army one would
think that this might be the way walkers
who have already been seen riding horses
but during the filming the White Walkers
are just guys in prosthetics and makeup
except for their blue eyes that are
added in post-production
the Queen's thoughts like the ones we
can see on these the track however are
used for rites the decayed skeletal kind
is achieved at the help of visual
effects hence the green suits the
clothing and saddles of these fights
also fitted track style these are
definitely the track White's the knight
king will conquer the north and the
living or least what's left of them
we'll have to retreat south and once
again partly with Sir
senior well Danny burnt sir seen a red
keeper will sir see burn King's Landing
the Wildfire or will Cersei finally
decides to join the great war is yet to
be seen but the teaser does imply that
the living fire will hit the dead ice
and the other way around fire nice race
towards the shatter freezing and burning
all in their path clashing near the
Three Forks of the river Trident a place
of great historical significance for
Westeros it will scare that Robert
Baratheon the fairy Jones fighter
Rhaegar Targaryen it was also here that
or in stark knelt Wigan Targaryen during
Aegon's conquest and it seemingly here
that another conflict between Ice and
Fire will take place in conclusion the
third episode of the final season will
be the bloodiest episode ever in Game of
Thrones besting the winds of winter and
the Battle of the bastards full of war
full of danger here's hoping some of our
favorites make it out alive and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]